[Music]  we in the European Commissioner once  again really proud to be supporting  project Edwards that's a European day  without a road death we are here this  morning to participate in this Belgian  police control check which is one of the  most effective ways in which we can  drive down speeds and make people safer  on the roads who knows perhaps one day  it'll be every day without a road  [Music]  you see that's a phrase  [Music]  did you enjoy it when you said  [Music]  absolutely the seat belts are so crucial  for the safety let go zero today focused  on no fatalities on European roads  project Edward  brings us together that we focus on what  matters most our lives only working  together we can achieve our ultimate  goal zero deaths and serious injuries on  European roads  you